we watched in horror as the Rohingya
fled mass killings and rapes and the
wholesale destruction of their homes at
the hands of the mime our military the
sky reported in 2017 hundreds of
thousands were forced to escape the
brutal crackdown but mime our leader
Aung San su Chi and Nobel Peace Prize
winner defended her country's conduct
today the International Court of Justice
rejected that defense myanmar must in
accordance with its obligations under
the Convention and in relation to the
members of their own injure group in its
territory take all measures within its
power to prevent the commission of all
acts within the scope of article 2 of
the Genocide Convention surely under the
circumstances genocide or intent cannot
be the only hypothesis the ruling is a
slap in the face for Aung San su Chi and
her personal intervention in the
hearings in today's financial time she
doubled down calling the allegations
against maíam are unproven statements
saying her country try to bring
stability and progress to Rakeem
province whether her hang years once
lived more than 600,000 fled to camps
were today they were celebrating the
decision in a court half a world away
I am very happy and grateful to Gambia
and pray for them I have seen the ruling
on television we have won it and it's a
win for all the Rohingya people the mom
our delegation left without comments the
ruling is provisional the final decision
could take years an action in the UN is
being blocked by Russia and China China
and Russia in the Security Council
it really is regretful and it is and
I've said this many times that it is
shameful for those states to not do
anything in the face of what took all
the evidence we have but the ruling
should be binding after all they've been
through it says the Rohingya still
facing ongoing threat and my mom must do
all it can to protect them their
supporters hope it's the first steps
towards bringing them justice Domenic
Waghorn Sky News